MIKE: Dani is sending us to Ken
and his sons, Rod and Randy.
Just like his sons, Ken was born
and raised in this little town.
So they bought an
old building downtown
to store all of the stuff
they've collected
over the years.
MIKE: Hey-hey!
ROD: Howdy!
MIKE: How're you doing?
ROD & RANDY: Good.
FRANK: Who's Rod
and who's Randy?
RANDY: I'm Randy.
FRANK: You're Randy.
ROD: I'm Rod.
MIKE: This is Rod, Frank.
FRANK: You're Rod.
How're you doin', I'm Frank.
Nice to meet ya.
MIKE: Nice to meet you.
So Danielle said
something about
your father wanting to
downsize a little bit,
but he wasn't ready to,
like, sell everything.
ROD: Right.
He's 83...
MIKE: Okay.
ROD: ...and he still has
a passion for it, but...
MIKE: Is he still buying?
ROD: If we let him!
MIKE: Yeah.
[laughter]
ROD: Well, I had some
heart-to-heart talks with Dad,
and I said "Dad, my kids are
wondering what they're gonna
"do with my stuff.
"Not even to mention,
"what are we gonna do
with all your stuff?"
FRANK: Frank.
MIKE: Hey, I'm Mike.
Very nice to meet you.
We appreciate you having us.
KEN: Good to know you guys.
MIKE: So these guys were saying
that you got your buddies still
coming out and
hanging out down here.
KEN: Oh, yeah.
That's what I like about this.
They can see when I'm here.
MIKE: Yeah.
FRANK: Oh, there you go.
KEN: And they'll stop in,
and that's when we have
our bull sessions, you know.
MIKE: Oh, yeah.
FRANK: Reminisce
about the old stuff?
MIKE: Bull session.
[laughs]
MIKE: Are these guys you went
to high school with and stuff?
KEN: Oh, yeah.
MIKE: No kiddin'!
FRANK: That's cool.
KEN: They're still here in town.
KEN: I raised my family
in the antique car hobby,
or whatever you
want to call it.
And they've grown up from
riding in the rumble seat
to driving their own cars.
KEN: My dad was a builder
here in Brady,
and I grew up working
off of his trucks.
And we supplied gravel for
this building when I was a kid,
and I didn't do
a whole lot of shoveling...
MIKE: Oh, when they were
pouring the floors in here?
KEN: Oh, yeah.
MIKE: No kidding.
MIKE: Ken remembers when this
building was being built,
which is pretty cool because
now it houses his collection.
KEN: I've amused myself now for
30 years with walking people
through this and explaining.
FRANK: Now, this is
a really cool moto-meter.
KEN: That's an early Model A.
FRANK: What I like about this
is most of them,
you have to unscrew.
KEN: Yeah, it's a flip top.
FRANK: This one you would
screw on, but look at that.
You can just open it
right up to fill it.
KEN: Do you know what
that little round hole is?
In the front of that?
FRANK: This little round,
in the back here?
KEN: Yeah.
When it's on the car...
FRANK: Um-hm.
KEN: At night, and you're
at the steering wheel,
if you look through that hole,
into your headlight pattern
out there on the ground...
FRANK: Okay.
KEN: ...you can see if that red
temperature thing's coming up.
MIKE: Oh, so you can see
the temperature at night.
FRANK: Well, I gotta ask...
Is this something
you would sell?
♪
KEN: Uh...
I'm gonna say yes.
FRANK: It's a beautiful piece.
KEN: Yeah.
FRANK: Um...
300?
KEN: You talked me into it.
FRANK: Alright, you got a deal.
[laughter]
KEN: I'm very much interested
in passing this stuff on
to somebody that knows
what they're doing.
MIKE: The beauty of raising
your kids in a small town
is that they get to have
the same experiences
that you had:
going to the same school,
cruising up and down
Main Street,
knowing a lot of
the same people.
The ripple effect of Ken's life
really resonates with his boys.
RANDY: Hey, this was a fun day.
MIKE: Appreciate ya.
KEN: None of us know
how long we're gonna live,
and that doesn't make a bit of
difference in the world except
I'm not ready to go yet
'cause I got a lot to do!
[honks horn]
FRANK: Take care, man!
ROD: So long, guys!